This continent knows the true meaning of racism.
Its peoples have both been perpetrators of racism
against others and themselves the victims
of an insane and murderous racist ideology.
We understood that we could not end the nightmare
by surrendering ourselves to the passion of hatred
and the spirit of vengeance and retribution.
We are striving to proceed in a manner
and towards a result,
which will ensure that all our people,
both black and white, emerge as victors.
We recognised President de Klerk
and his colleagues in the National Party
as men and women of integrity.
We are therefore prepared to work with them,
to arrive at a just and lasting negotiated solution.
It must result in the transformation of South Africa
into a united, democratic and non-racial country.
Anything less than this would condemn our country
to worsening and economic conflict.
Every adult South African
must have the right to participate
in governing our country
through a system of one person, one vote.
The human rights of all our citizens
must be guaranteed.
The apartheid system in our country continues.
We continue to be ruled
by a white minority government.
All the other pillars of the apartheid system
have not yet been removed.
The masses of our people
must therefore continue the struggle
within our own country.
The international community shares the same obligation.
We thank you most sincerely,
for awarding us with the Sakharov Prize.
We take it as a challenge, above all,
to have the courage to fight for justice and peace,
whatever the obstacles.
We shall try not to fail you.
Thank you.